hello there how are you I'm good uh
about yourself I'm good my two torture
okay they're just not saying anything
I'm good I'm listening I feel like I've
been talking a lot so I'm gonna shut up
yeah
um so where are you from cold cold place
call Michigan oh yeah okay yeah yeah you
were shy right you know that should a
zoo yeah
I wouldn't call where me and torsa is
from around me and torso from Chiraq wow
they used to call it that I work in this
thing
yeah you know you go there for the food
get shot it's like a saying it sounds
bad it's like a Chicago line I'm just
saying
it's [ __ ] hilarious but you know
whatever you ever seen any rappers out
there no I know some I know like chance
and [ __ ] you don't chance we talk about
this yeah get him get him on my Channel
please
cool dude I'm sure he would just ask him
you're like no no I'm saying like how
just message
his stuff like his Instagram and stuff
his entourage is pretty cool too
probably the only Entourage that I am
cool with next time I'm in Chicago I
might yeah Waka Flocka was cool T.I was
cool
G-Eazy was weird sorry
music I thought he was black I'm not
even a lot
yes
I'm just saying like I think a lot of
people thought that because normally
when you hear a white rapper they would
sound like Eminem like with Laurie do
you know who I'm talking about he sounds
like Eminem he's a white rapper
but
yeah he does
you know I thought he was gonna be
really cool and he just was really
really strange strange dude not a fan
I don't know what it is yeah I don't
know
I could at times
can I guess your age
a lot of people
no that was wrong 23. uh 25. that's what
I'll do wait hold up let me do this hold
on stand up 100
. stop it everyone shut up 150 dollars
oh
thank you so much that is the biggest
donation I've ever gotten it's on the
screen oh how do I do it all right
that's a dollar am I tripping that's a
dollar sign some one time it was
Japanese currency yeah that's like about
78 cents to the dollar or something like
that oh my God but this isn't right I'm
not tripping I don't want to get too
excited thank you
[ __ ] thank you
guys just love to hear you thank them
not all the girls wear cakes without a
sugar daddy in the house oh my gosh I'm
so excited yay she gets to get her thing
now okay
I mean yeah that's all you want it right
okay and up let me see
you gotta be 21.
21 uh close yeah you're young I do at
the bar for sure you don't got to do all
that that's a I'm a bartender
I'd want to know your address I'm
kidding I love using that line that's a
little creepy is it though guys love it
and they're like really you're gonna ID
me and not my friend I'm like I just
want your address and they're the only
the only reason I said 25 is because you
said that I would get it wrong so I
thought you were older than like you
looked but like the the jerseys on the
wall I was like he's got to be young
he's got to be in in college he's a term
that not a lot of people know called
black don't crack so I don't know that's
why what it is wait what is that
crack I've never heard that you never
heard of it no really
too blacked in oh man what is this thank
you for the donation chosen
152. oh look oh look more people
donating bless them
thank you to all the memes
also the next thing I'm gonna be
fundraising for is a microphone for the
hot [ __ ] so just you know the next
thing anyways oh
this idea what said you're really going
through with this podcast idea yeah I
just think I have girls on my team like
from Japan Germany like all over the
world so I think it'd be really cool to
get them in here and have something set
up where I could do a live show yeah
broadcaster is that what you're getting
I'm assuming yeah yeah because that is
the most Outlets yeah I wanna I just
yeah
um what do you so you're in Michigan are
you in school yeah how old are you show
me your it I feel like this is wrong
whoa whoa whoa let me see your ID let me
see your ID Ain't Nothing Gonna have me
online saying anything
why are you telling me no I'm not gonna
reach your ass
I'm over to age 18. let me see your ID
he's [ __ ] tripping you're not you're
not 18. okay I'm saving me in Pearl from
this one
that's the 18th it's still wrong okay is
it like
it's so 17 year old boy you remember my
age it's still wrong
17 about a year ago what else I don't
believe you I don't believe you don't
believe me but you really want to see my
ID that bad yeah yeah it's not gonna
happen
yeah my my he's got to be young all
right sir
oh no we can't not if I don't I gotta
know that if you're 18.
you're not easy
my boy don't crack that bad
I don't know what that means
what does it mean Alex donovania tell
you
Donovan what's this mean
nice try though okay I appreciate that
you wanted us to guess okay that gave us
the hint oh look I got it right here
don't worry about the picture how is uh
yeah let me see let me see if this is a
fake okay it's standing upright is it
expired it's expensive let me see bring
it all the way to you really want to see
my address that bad no hide that [ __ ]
uh expired 11
10 25 25 is when it expires it's hard to
read it's fake 11 24. no wait uh 10 31
25. when were you born I didn't see
anything in the 90s that's actually a
crazy fact about going on Halloween oh
no [ __ ] that's awesome it's a blessing
in the curse
astrology girls and then oh yeah that's
true
so it is it is what it is yeah that is
the thing if you guys want to get a girl
to really think that y'all are serious
text her at 11 11. she'll think it's
because of her crystals I actually tried
that I got left and right don't try that
oh dang it yeah you gotta first
establish something I believe you that
you're 20. I believe it I don't believe
him dude his ideas vertical that that's
like they're like they're like that in
Michigan my friend's from Michigan
think he's 21. [ __ ] no I think he's
20. he said 20. I'll say I never heard
him leave a number I don't believe him
you can read him I won't
it's not illegal at least here
Carl gets arrested no now I'm rethinking
this why do you think
I'm 18. I'm 18. I don't know I don't
trust you oh no I just showed you the ID
that's my point
this [ __ ] I'm too trusting oh no yeah
you're like I believe I was like no okay
we are not getting arrested
foreign
because I would have just believed him
he said okay okay I'm 18. I was like oh
yeah no he's not
I'm too trusting I just like believe
people